now in south africa at least 15 people
are dead after a mass shooting at a bar
in the johannesburg township of soweto
police said a group of men arrived in a
taxi entered a tavern and began shooting
randomly at customers shortly before
midnight on saturday
police are still searching for the
attackers and their motive local
authorities described the incident as a
massacre in a separate incident four
people were killed in a shooting in a
tavern in the east of the country
although police do not believe the two
attacks were linked
i am joined now by journalist sifa
kemmer in east london south africa hello
sifa the suspects are on the run what
have the police shared if anything about
the men they are looking for
well as of late um as you know as you've
also mentioned that the identity
still remains unknown apart
from that one true that they actually
fled uh in a white mini bus um they
lifted the scene then and of course uh
giving intel on the firearm that was
used it said that uh they had used
rifles as well as a nine millimeter
pistols um to actually you know bring
rain upon that tavern uh
late evening on saturday so as far as
the information
regarding the perpetrators uh there's
still an investigation and it is still
sketchy uh including the shooting itself
now let's talk about the victims do we
know if
they were the specific targets in the
attacks
i mean the police for now are saying
that it appears to be a random shooting
looking at some of the victims of course
that were caught up in that fire in that
massacre it seems as though the victims
ages they ranged between 19 years as
well as 39 years of age at the police
for now saying that they do not suspect
that there was any specific target but
of course uh this is a developing story
and of course they're still
investigating the scene and the
circumstances surrounding this shooting
that has of course stunned this entire
entire community off orlando east
so
do we know anything yet about the reason
for the shooting in soweto
i mean it is a random act and that's
what the police are saying for now
while they still busy with the
investigations but what i can tell you
is as far as you have also mentioned
that it's been alleged that um gunman
entered a television in orlando east
soweto in south africa and randomly
opened fire to the unsuspecting patrons
uh of course that then the gunman fled
the scene in a white mini bus of course
leaving 15 dead and one critically um
you know
stable in a hospital currently and also
looking at the firearms that we're using
um we are supposing that the police are
identifying the firearm so that whoever
has any information uh can come forward
saying that rifles were used as well as
nine millimeter pistols
okay assassin's motive is still not
clear safakema in east london thank you